- What is this!?
What?
- Today I'm trying an ombre lip,
is that what it's called?
- You just kind of apply
it in the center right,
if you have a second color, no, yes, no.
- I don't know if it's a
competition but I want to win.
- What!?
(laughs)
Oh my god!
(upbeat fun music)
- I've never actually like
really used a selfie stick.
- Okay like this?
- [Voiceover] Yeah.
Great.
- Okay!
- Apply to the center of
the lips and then smudge.
That doesn't seem that hard.
- Agh, I can't.
- F**k.
- Oh man, ah I just got my tooth.
- Okay, ew, ugh, ew, ew ew ew.
- Oh god this is terrible. F**k!
F**k!
- I was looking forward to doing this.
- How is it, it's not, oh dear, oh god.
- I can't use this hand,
well I guess I could use it.
Nope that's not gonna work, I'm too short.
- I don't even know what
the point of the smudger is.
- Okay we're gonna have to.
(laughs)
The audio on this probably sounds so nice.
(elongated ahhing)
- Oh my god, I look like a clown.
(ahhing continues)
(blows air out)
- It's in my mouth, it's
in, is, it's in my mouth.
- Yup, looks great.
- Looks like I've been
making out with someone
a little bit but that's okay.
- So I would give myself a solid B.
- I think I did okay for
what I had going for me.
- I just got it on the mirror.
I think I just ruined it.
- Oh my god!
Wait, I'm so sorry!
- I think selfie sticks have
one use and this was not it.
- This is weird, this
whole thing is weird.
This trend is weird, this stick is weird,
everything is weird.